buonasera a tutti mi chiamo salvo giunta
o 30 anni sono un di un direttore
creativo di uno studio che si occupa di
motion design in questa presentazione mi
spiegherò brevemente il mio percorso
lavoro attivo quindi partendo dagli
studi dello ied per poi arrivare al
lavoro che si svolgono oggi io ho
frequentato il corso di graphic design
allo ied di milano sono di origine
siciliane mi sono trasferito appunto a
milano per per frequentare il corso di
grafica dello ied
per me già trasferirmi da una piccola
città del sud in sicilia una grande
città come milano è stato veramente un
un modo per ricevere
tanti stimoli e tanti spunti che fino ai
18 anni non avevo potuto avere
all'inizio
diciamo quando iniziato a studiare
grafica
avevo tante idee però dal punto di vista
tecnico non ero molto bravo
quindi il primo anno è stato abbastanza
difficile riuscire a far funzionare
insieme la testa ei software
questo e questo mi ricordo è stato il
primo la prima lezione di photoshop che
abbiamo fatto a scuola
quindi squadra il mio livello di
partenza
come potete vedere abbastanza abbastanza
basse e quindi era abbastanza
demoralizzato perché molte persone
comunque nella mia classe aveva già
fatto un corso di già studiato grafica
al al liceo e quindi con un approccio
già sicuramente più più evoluto rispetto
al mio
però diciamo che con il passare del
tempo soprattutto dal secondo anno in
poi sono riuscito a portarmi al passo
con gli altri miei compagni
diciamo che dal secondo anno in poi
dello ied
più che vedere la grafica come uno
studio per me era diventata proprio una
passione quindi andare a casa non andava
a casa per fare il compito gli esercizi
da consegnare al prof andava a casa per
studiare imparare qualcosa che a me
piace veramente tanto
dopo lo yen
ha iniziato un periodo dove ho fatto
diversi colloqui diversi studi agenzie
però realtà mai trovato nessun post che
riusciva a che è una delle
caratteristiche che mi piacessero a
livello lavorativo e progettuale tanti
miei studi grandi con tanti clienti però
volevo fare qualcosa di mio
cosa a cui teniamo veramente tanto
quindi con degli altri ragazzi che sono
finito lui ed è sempre in quell'anno
abbiamo deciso di metter su uno studio
che sembra studio morin che era formato
da persone che si occupavano di
discipline diverse
a roma in cinque c'era chi si occupava
di grafica cio che si occupa di
fotografia e chi di moda kg design
studio morì me è stato un modo che ci ha
aiutato sicuramente a crescere perché
erano le prime volte in cui ci
approcciamo ad un cliente la prima volta
in cui sentiamo un commercialista
la prima volta in cui devo fare una
fattura e diciamo che
stare l'uno vicino all'altro ci è
servito come supporto o un altra cosa
interessante dello studio è che
lavorando in settori diversi
abbiamo potuto avere un giro di clienti
da diciamo da scambiarsi quindi a volte
eravamo in due marchi chi era un grafico
e chi si occupa di fotografia a lavorare
sullo stesso progetto
in questo modo c'è stato anche un una
condivisione uno scambio di idee quindi
ok io ho studiato grafica ma non mi
occupavo soltanto di grafica o comunque
ero a contatto con altre
discipline penso che questa questa
formazione diciamo subito dopo la scuola
con altre persone che si occupiamo di
altre discipline
e stato fondamentale per lo sviluppo e
il lavoro che faccio adesso
questo qua mi ricordo è stato il mio
primo approccio con i clienti o che è
subito dopo scuola quando ho iniziato a
lavorare
era un po difficile riuscire a proporre
un'idea un concetto ad un cliente
molte volte la risposta era un po questo
schiaffo in faccia
ok perché mari eravamo molto giovani ho
21 anni quindi magari andare a 21 anni
da un cliente a proporre un'idea mari il
trend di guardava in faccia insomma un
ragazzino cosa cosa stai dicendo
quindi questo è stato il mio primo
approccio lavorativo che però
per fortuna nel corso degli anni è
cambiato adesso sicuramente riusciamo
più a metterci alla pari col cliente
comunque riuscire avere un dialogo più
più di scambio mtb
nel 2007 si realizza uno dei miei più
grandi sogni cioè quello di andare a
lavorare in tv sin dal secondo anno
dello ied
la mia passione è uno dei miei stimoli
più grandi era mtv uk guardavamo tipi
quelle grafiche andavano in onda e
impazzivo ci dice voglio far questo qua
nel 2007 grazie un mio precedente dello
yen dovuto modo di fare questo colloquio
è quindi ho iniziato a lavorare come
motion designer all'interno del canale
mi ricordo dall'inizio fu qualcosa di
veramente difficile io all'inizio
guardava in tv e copiavo in tv prende
spunto dai motivi per fare i miei lavori
arrivato dentro in tv non potevo più
prendere spunto dai miti v
dovevo essere io a creare qualcosa di
nuovo e diverso rispetto la grafica che
si vedeva nella grafica e rispetto la
grafica degli altri canali
mi ricordo una cosa che mi disse il mio
collega che mi mimì riscossa abbastanza
era cosa qua tu adesso sera in tv adesso
sei tu a fare dei progetti che la gente
deve copiare quella per me pura frase
veramente non ci dormi per quattro
giorni di fila perché dovevo riuscire a
creare del design tira fuori delle idee
di un certo livello e di un certo tipo
mi ricordo che per il primo progetto mi
facevo lavorare alla realizzazione di
una sigla televisiva e meno che per tre
mesi di fila face sempre lo stesso
progetto inizio il progetto arrivo a
metà meno bocciavano fanno ad iniziare
non va bene deve essere impostato in
questo modo
l'inizio rifai ribocciato questa cosa
per chi votare 4 volte ero veramente
demoralizzato però alla fine di quel
periodo che per me è stato come una
seconda scuola come una specializzazione
ho avuto il modo la fortuna di stare a
contatto con persone che tenevo
veramente al lavoro che svolgevano con
un'impronta mare un po più particolare
rispetto
maggior parte degli studi di milano
italiani 2007 nel 2007 fu contattato
dallo ied perché mi proposero di
ritornare a scuola ma non come alunno ma
questa volta come
come assistente di tesi quindi dopo due
anni ritorna a scuola e non ero più
dietro al banco ma dall'altra parte
della cattedra per me quella fu
un'esperienza molto importante anche
perché poi negli anni successivi
passai da assistente di te sia docenti
adesso insegna al al terzo anno del
corso di grafica insegno design grafica
televisiva quello che faccio no è che
quello che faccio adesso la cosa che amo
tanto dello ied è la possibilità di
confrontarmi con ragazzi molto più
giovani
per me è una cosa molto importante
perché penso che stare in un ambiente
diverso dall ambiente lavorativo
commenti più fresche a volte magari
anche un po ingenuo perché aveva un
ragazzo scuola chiaramente la pensa in
un modo diverso in professionista però
penso programmi permette di ricevere
nuovi stimoli vedere nuovi siti
parla di cose che magari a volte darei
per scontato per me la la figura
all'interno dello ied è molto importante
spero che questa cosa possa durare nel
tempo
detroit detroit
lo studio che abbiamo un fondato io un
mio amico
e io adesso sono socio fondatore e
direttore creativo dello studio uno
studio 2010
sicuramente alla base dello studio c'è
la passione per me svegliarmi la mattina
andare in studio
non l'ho mai per essere come un lavoro
ma come una passione e penso sia quella
cosa che
se abbiamo fatto crescere è più che
altro abbia fatto funzionare lo studio
noi ci occupiamo di direzione artistica
di design e animazione lavoriamo tanto
con
la tv reg realizziamo format viene
avanti per programmi ma ci capita di
realizzare il video per qualsiasi per
qualsiasi
piattaforma cioè dal web agli eventi
alla televisione ai teatri con detroit
un'altra cosa molto importante che mi
hanno fatto è creare un network di
persone nei collaboratori di base in
studio centre e ma collaboriamo con
tante persone
sparsi in tutta italia anche all'estero
questo perché ci piace aver
continuamente uno scambio di idee e
anche un modo per confrontarsi tenendo
se tenendo tanto lavoro che facciamo
un'altra cosa
che che vogliamo fare è ogni volta per
ogni determinato tipo di progetto
inserire su quel progetto la persona più
adatta quindi sia un progetto che va più
verso le illustrazioni coinvolgiamo
degli illustratori di un determinato
tipo se un progetto
da fare con delle foto spara casa ci
piace coinvolgere dei fotografi
specializzati a far quello questa qua è
un è un'immagine che ho trovato su
internet un po di tempo fa ed è una
frase che rispecchia molto la nostra
filosofia è la filosofia dello studio
work for money design molto spesso
non ci passiamo un po su questo concetto
quando ci approcciamo con un cliente con
un nuovo cliente in molti casi se il
cliente non permette o comunque un
cliente tavolette intelligente che vuole
creare un prodotto un progetto di un
determinato tipo cercando un confronto
con lo studio quindi con noi e non
imponendosi sullo studio a volte siamo a
volte molto spesso siamo anche disposti
a trovare degli accordi economici ad
abbassare i budget pur di fare un
progetto con determinate caratteristiche
e valori quando il cliente magari è un
po più rompipalle permettetemi il
termine applichiamo la prima fa alla
prima fase work for money
ok non c'è uno scambio di idee c'è un
imposizione da parte tua
non ha rispetto ma nel nostro lavoro
allora in cui in quel punto vogliamo più
l'aspetto economico però quando è
possibile c'è la nostra vera frase la
seconda design for love e cioè quindi
far qualcosa che amiamo veramente e ci
piace farlo in quattro anni abbiamo
avuto la possibilità e la fortuna di
lavorare con tantissimi clienti dal
dallo sport alla moda alle automobili
all'intrattenimento
la cosa interessante di lavorare con
tutti questi clienti è l'approccio di
ogni cliente
c'è chi interessa un aspetto c'è chi
interessa molto aspetto c'è chi ha delle
idee
chi la pensa in un modo chi la pensa ad
altro modo e in questo caso penso che a
volte anche il cliente a farci crescere
perché chiaramente non ci mette sempre
in di gioco e ci confrontiamo con
diverse realtà e con diversi temi
federica moretti
anch'io ho fatto lo ied ma tutta
un'altra diciamo storia sono venuta a
milano da modena
con l'intento di essere una fotografa e
tra le traduzioni anche di moda finiti
gli studi invece o altro non si sa come
e perché ho deciso di iniziare a fare
cappelli quindi oltretutto lavorare
nella moda
questo percorso è iniziato ben dieci
anni fa ormai e con tante difficoltà ma
contenta di aver le diciamo passate di
avere scelto questa questa strada perché
subito era passione voi adesso e
passione e lavoro allo stesso tempo i
primi anni sono stati difficili perché
comunque non ho avuto una formazione
nell'ambito del cappello della
modisteria quindi non essendoci neanche
scuole o comunque persone che ti possano
insegnare questo tipo di lavoro perché
comunque in italia non c'è praticamente
più nessuno un lavoro che piano piano
sta scomparendo
ho dovuto iniziare anche un po se si
vuol dire da sola poi fortunatamente
qua cinque anni fa ho avuto la fortuna
di lavorare entrare a lavorare nel team
borsalino che
è per eccellenza il brand italiano di
cappelli e lì ho imparato il vero e
proprio mestiere di cappellaia diciamo
così facciamoli italianizzata e in
questo contesto non era più soltanto la
mia vena creativa dove tanto tutto si
può mettere in testa qualsiasi cosa la
possiamo fare indossare
ho dovuto anche affrontare problematiche
che un'azienda di quel tipo doveva
affrontare e quindi cambiare
completamente la mia visione del lavoro
quello che era per me creare cappelli e
questa grande occasione che loro mi
hanno dato per che hanno creduto in me è
un'azienda storica di così tanti anni
far entrare nel loro team una ragazza
giovane perché
ero giovane e da lì carta bianca sullo
stile tutto per me è stato veramente
molto importante mi hanno veramente
aiutato e forse è stata la mia
grandissima scuola e di esperienza l'ho
fatta lì da loro
dopo questa esperienza che è stata anche
impegnativa
ho deciso nel 2011 di iniziare una mia
collezione e quindi di non essere più
una sola designer o creativa ma di
mettere insieme una vera e propria
azienda che disegnava produce consegna
insomma tutte le varie iter di un brand
di moda e questo l'ho potuto fare adesso
dico grazie allo studio che faccio parte
sempre come salvatore a studio morin
perché nei primi periodi
a vent'anni probabilmente abbiamo
iniziato questa strada perché non
sapevamo che cosa andavamo incontro
quali sarebbero state le difficoltà
quindi ingenuamente orientale veneto ma
si cominciano forse 25 abbiamo detto ma
cosa abbiamo fatto
a trenta siamo contenti insomma di aver
intrapreso questa strada
quindi devo dire grazie a loro che in un
momento nei momenti difficili che ci
sono stati eravamo tutti lì insieme
scherzando si diceva da domani
nonostante tutto prima si parlava di
nonostante tutto noi ne abbiamo detto di
nonostante tutto è un'altra cosa che si
parlava prima erano i genitori devo
ringraziare anche loro perché
inventandomi un mestiere è stato
difficile soprattutto all'inizio
iniziare a rendere vero questo sogno o
questa visione che mi ero immaginata e
insomma anche grazie a tutti voi perché
mi avete ospitato qua
finisco perché sono già sempre fuori più
infantino